Une chanson bien calibrée
Avec un peu de guitare manouche
Sinon c'est louche
Mais je sais pas en jouer
Quelques sonorités ibériques
sur une mélodie bien typique
Recette classique
à chaque fois je me fais du fric
Je suis gitan ce sont mes origines
Je me dois de vous le rappeler
Même si j'ai troqué ma caravane pour une berline
En général pour le refrain
j'ai ma leçon d'espagnol niveau 1
Et je lis ce qui vient
¿ Hola qué tal ?
¿Cómo te llamas ?
Te quiero
Me llamo Kendjo
bailando
¿ Cuál es la fecha de hoy ?
Rafael Nadal
Observez bien autour de moi
tout le monde est souriant et très gai
Mais ça fait seulement 15 minutes qu'on se connaît
Et puis cette fille vêtue de blanc, qui connaît par coeur ma chanson,
Ce qu'elle veut c'est son cachet d'intermittent
¿ Hola qué tal ?
¿Cómo te llamas ?
Te quiero
Me llamo Kendjo bailando
¿ Cuál es la fecha de hoy ?
Rafael Nadal
Hola chicas !
¿Dónde está el autobús ?
Vamos a la playa conmigo
La cuenta por favor
Rafael Nadal